we changed our loadouts for the next one
we actually want the BIOS scanners and
turrets and we don't really need sea
foams if you want to do turrets seafoam
boys you can do but the bio track just
like a radar thing and you have to aim
it so you're responsible for spotting
and Wayde and I are responsible for
hammering response oh so we just need
one bio trekker one in all turrets is
probably fine verbal is the mind
deployer any good I honestly haven't
used it I don't know
I'll do the mine just to see what it is
so we know if it's a lethal sea foam
yeah if we like plant and have like
retreat out this door and you can just
poop out a mine in the doorway and then
we [ __ ] run for it oh you could be
ran yeah you could be the last guy you
could leave a trail of Mines I mean I
will this is a lot of responses you have
to say no Stacy
oh hey Bros hi friends this is very
matrix I love it I'm sorry arts beat
what is that the same thing yeah it's
the same thing
hi Flor it's kind of a chasm I shouldn't
know I shouldn't have laughed that
that's a cheap joke I'm a hack this box
will [ __ ] heard dude hacking dammit
oh there are enemies in the main lobby
okay so if I remember right this room is
a real [ __ ] and a half to clear it's a
big-ass room and there's enemies all
over it
for now Alamo is get the [ __ ] back to
this door and defend this Elmo Alamo
so Alamo is like our safe word bio
tracker man bio tracker man go first oh
that's yeah it's a good idea good good
okay so I see a white dot on the Left Oh
God
should I should I shoot him with it no
it won't oh they're not moving literally
won't do anything there's there's three
dots there's one of the right one
forward and one left how close is the
one on the right to me oh is that speak
one down there oh that's a big ones big
that's a big big one okay which is clear
yeah there's four in this room he's like
right there right behind those forklifts
okay you got it bud Oh
imagine if this game had [ __ ] in-game
voice laughs [ __ ] game voice there's
five of them in this room and I'm
squishing them in a second here whenever
he comes
I wait for that squelch do you [ __ ] yeah
everyone looks calm big guys still come
okay so the guy on our left is the
nearest one after that then Bob you have
another one on your right is he gonna
die what from one hit he's very big
well one will one hit kill a hammer and
a small head weight and you do it wait
you have you do it
all right Marco are we you and me I move
the second left guy far from this guy
he's yeah a little bit not too far oh
he's so good he's holding even me
oh no okay why did we send the dum-dum
can't even get his head from yeah we can
stand up next to them it's okay just
don't move so this is arm stops moving
okay if you touch them it will trigger
so like okay demon where y'all touch you
I'm going for we gotta go go go
he's still alive very much very much
alive okay he's dead he's dead he's dead
I'm getting wait up I gotta get wait up
- still Alamo I got to get wait up oh
they're coming form it they're stopping
okay right side it's coming our right
side coming back coming back wait get up
wait don't don't let it touch it we just
run wait go away go Kurt's turning
shirts John everyone incident in in in
in okay Jesus
so I don't know how we pissed him off
cuz I don't think he touched us did he
do you I think when you stood up so I
think standing up is only when we're
about to go big we stop II oh he's so
stop II Jack can you can you track him
can you bio track whoa oh god oh god I'm
getting hit by something okay he tongue
whipped you I think he's dead
okay I'm at 50% health that's two and a
half times what I've got yeah I managed
huh yeah yeah biceps like Dwayne the
rock [ __ ] alien yeah so big guys
cannot go down in one hit is what we
discovered to just avoid them so another
thing that was weird is I went to click
to hold to power up and just instantly
swung so I gave him like a weak little
tap on the bunker - yeah
did you right-click cuz right-click is
like a crowd control pushy no no no I
was holding left click okay yeah just
like it just swung feels good to be the
one at 100% health for the first time
ever I was a hero
I saved Wade he would I didn't get him
okay Shh
there's three dudes through the wall on
this side where I am yeah with the bio
tracker you can see through doors and
whatnot so you guys need to shut off
next time you [ __ ] get to take down
the Jolly Green [ __ ] yeah you
volunteer don't believe it volunteer
come hey wait I got a med pack over come
on what are we looking for twelve
personalities so our next door should
probably be this one because there's
less dudes through it but it's an alarm
one the other door to our North has six
of them behind it but I don't think it's
an allowable well six is in a province
called is the big dude suck my fears
have we set off an alarm all the dudes
in the non alarm doors nearby are gonna
burst through detect any way I don't
know if that's true but it just feels
this is the keycard door down here red
seven nine eight okay we have one ID in
zone
forty this one this one goes to
yes the keycard door goes to 40 wait
that one doesn't say that it has an
alarm on it right which one the one I
met yeah start security scan yeah this
one has like a big red warning alarm
detected I'm a similar security scan
also means it'll be a sequence cuz it's
a sequence yeah but it's not an alarm
yes 39 and 40 are the ones and then we
have another ID in zone 47 zone 40 yeah
key red seven nine eight we have three
IDs in zone forty so forty I think is a
good place for us to go
well no it's it's good the keycard door
yeah just go through red seven nine
eight ping that [ __ ] hang out of range
keycard red seven nine eight is in zone
forty-three okay that's over here the
keycard okay so we need to get the key
card and put this one's the alarm so I
don't know which was no we need to turn
it up for this one yeah I mean it seems
like a pretty decent choke point if I
had a choice and we have high ground as
also we have time I'm gonna just is it
just as a test I'm gonna I'm gonna put a
mine here just because I want to see how
it works yeah yeah yeah or ooh where the
circle is gonna be one no [ __ ] yeah it's
not shooting anything is it like I have
to stick it on like a wall or something
or a door yeah whoa look at everything
it says there's something on the door
does it like blow doors open yeah let me
i'ma hold off on that alright ready
let's do this [ __ ] I really hope they
can't climb up these sides left side
Oh going oh god oh no oh no oh god oh
gosh
police don't shoot me in the back of the
head oh god oh god this is not this is
done I deal I don't even know how Oh
freaking frack oh I'm trying to get to
my spot I swear I'm down to like 23% of
health I'm I got a big guy on the spot I
was trying to go to I'm down upstairs
wow that guy's big I think it got him I
popped his head anyway that was the oh
he's not dead
ah [ __ ] more coming in I think I have
one I think I have one option and it's
to die over here - we don't have a
bleed-out Dewey doesn't look like it I
don't think so oh my god turrets please
why is he crab scooting up that's so
weird
Jesus oh my god the church didn't do
anything oh my god I just saw flashing
all right so alarmed or is a bad door
yeah alarmed or I don't know maybe maybe
that would help that's the only option I
had for using the mine was good God on a
door wait why do i why do I still have
enter security scan to stop alarm okay
we have five dudes in here
Sean you're late sorry can you tell what
kind of enemies they are through that or
is it just like I'm down there just just
a white duck okay one right down we
weren't at the bottom of the stairs on
your side and one another one two over
there close together yeah oh god there's
so many in this room I can get the one
directly to the right of the bottom of
the stairs right below us there's like
four of them right down here on my side
of the stairs there's like it's hard to
tell they're like all clump together
right and ones getting freaky I think we
can take these two out on the Left can't
we yeah if you take that one right next
to you is it gonna trigger the one
behind it yeah very close should I go to
the one behind the stairs behind me then
no just
I think let mark and I just do these two
okay I don't know how close this one was
behind me it's okay I mean I'm
instructed I am not yet okay right okay
I think another one's going to hear that
from here they're all very close to each
other I think so let's do it
worst case scenario yeah arching now
okay and three two one murder
good kay you guys nice okay hey I I did
it you guys see the two on the far right
right there's one upstairs at the door
and one down at the archway right at the
door upstairs there's like three
literally humping each other on this
radar we just got to keep going slowly
Hey see where that walkway is I got one
right in front of me right oh yeah yeah
see he's glowing right now also mark go
job popping your cherry Thank You Man
thank you yeah okay you got it it's a
lot messier than I thought it'd be so
now we need to go up I feel like it's
[ __ ] if they see a sloven global
chill chill no one no one no one nothing
no one's doing I'm a lead I'm gonna
leave the chart on this bad boy I just
flushed my latest the staircase right
here to make sure I wasn't to make sure
they're still there
Bob's approaching an enemy I'm just
flashing my flashlight and skirting
around shooting my shot gamer okay we're
all clear we haven't won more ahead of
me over here I don't think the ones
above can detect us if they're not on
the same level right there to the right
well there's - all this - there's - oh
that is good info okay I can't tell if
they're upper or lower anyways so
there's like three in a ball right there
all right there's three there are three
you're right there are three that's a
problem also there's one close to me and
then there's Jeff further
I can I can try to go for the further
one okay are you good to go no wait wait
wait
mark says claw marks is flowing no
that's actually not mine that's that's
Wade's if he's coming up for this one
god I am right nice which did I hit my
flashlight right face by exit okay
you're safe I am in range in range you
are
Oh golly are there four here there's one
of you there's one above you that we're
watching I'm staring at two side-by-side
market you buy this much behind the
white far away
I'm right here ma'am all right I'm in
range okay ready yeah start charging now
all right
I swear I'm alibi hold it
okay something's bugged with Wade's
hammer humbug that's the second time
it's alright it's okay Wade God what hit
me
Turks out outside I don't know why that
happened again it's okay it's not your
fault okay we've seen that save your
your big ammo for the big boy okay and
if they're the ones in the back that are
shooting white crap out of their heads
yes are the bad ranged ones okay why
does it charge now
it's when you're in a panic situation
that's what do you see what do you see
there's nothing there's nothing yeah
we're clear that worked out okay that
actually I don't know why that happened
that's annoying it is but you know
that's not great for situations where we
must be stealthy so through this door
there are 10 of them Oh neat and they're
all together Oh neat I feel like we
should go non alarm just head of them
but you know I agree we should alarm to
our last is that a key code or this one
on West is key code or red 90 and there
are a lot of them somebody has a good
point can mark just bombed the card door
I don't know a that's how it works
I can go try let's see what happens
nothing nothing happens this gun that's
just it can't be used oh I have to be
close to the ground or the wall to place
it it's not like a fire it away
ah interest wait can you do it anywhere
then yes now I can do it now I see I can
do it anywhere I can put it on the
ground so how about we open this door
and you just put a mine down and we [ __ ]
it up no you don't like that please
so are things going to attack us while
we open this door because it's not alarm
but it is a security scan all right in
this go you I don't know man
should we put down so I'm just saying
there's ten of them behind this door
that I can see so it's heard your lights
off okay maybe but maybe put your
turrets down just in case here I'll be
ready to put one right here to like
cover the doorway a little bit all right
I will not put it until all hell breaks
loose and what I open is everyone ready
yes yeah oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
well there's no yelling yeah it seems
okay so there's no alarm okay chill easy
okay okay I'm gonna get back in a turret
position oh god I'm so this is gonna be
[ __ ] hell mark you got the one right
here on the left yeah what is ass
showing to us killing those two the one
straight ahead it's not far enough away
is it I don't know
so which one is mine standing boy no no
no I'm standing you're the guy in the
other lawyer for this right yeah
straight north boy wait so which one's
my oh I didn't see that one crouching
gone okay crouching left man is yours
got it understood oh there's a no wait
wait wait there's another guy right
behind that wall if there's a wall to
the right of Bob's one and there's a guy
right there I mean so we're gonna grumpy
do we want to mine up and turn at the
door I I say we take what we can get and
then just run yeah at least we get some
of them without wasting our ammo alright
ready start charging now and three two
one murder young okay okay okay sure it
up
nice whoa there's a lot more than I
thought there was gonna be holy [ __ ]
god what the hell ah mark puts the mines
out [ __ ] I got here I got it I'm getting
a little Oh getting a little uh a lot of
people a lot of lot of Oh God said it no
still some up wait one more out
okay Marky yeah I'm good I was like 20
of them that was a lot done at 12%
century just so we knew yeah 19% century
yeah I'll do the mines next time this is
a big room careful yeah yeah yeah more
click same room or same room not safe
not safe I see him I'm seeing five just
in this little area yeah there's three
together and then there's two slightly
further away okay oh yeah I see one
stand
so there we got the close guy standing
up straight behind him there's one on
his knees I think can we try and get
this one man yeah I think well that rain
there's one behind that barrel yeah
that's the next door okay
oh yeah there's there's five in that
direction I only see four right now so
I'm you know one might be behind a wall
I think we can get these guys I think we
can get these be ready in case my stupid
thing doesn't work again yeah we go like
eight times just do you want me to go so
far one wait coming around to help yeah
I should probably come and help with the
last we're gonna do all four of these at
the same time if we're doing anyone
other five I spy the next there's five
okay Bob be careful when you're
traversing the darkness cuz there's
there is they like right in the middle
I'm gonna get this guy on the right
chill okay so we need to get that fifth
one quickly I'm in position
Oh God
where is it I don't see it Oh what was
that
Oh God that was a I think that was a I
got Alamo yep yep jesus [ __ ] christ
right here oh god why aren't they dying
there's so many more coming in
we're working Christ we got I thought
there's a big big baby
okay okay okay good music still pumping
wait let me see oh my god there's some
overhears yeah next room yeah we're good
oh no no no we're not
they came from behind it oh my god it's
hard to know which ones are dating and
which ones are just crawling around yeah
yeah oh my god wait I almost shot you in
the head sorry I was trying to shoot
Shawn in the head then I crossed into
your flight okay no moving targets I am
out of turret ammo I have two bullets my
turret is also out those fun why are
they all clumped up so so oh one more
one more coming at you Shawn Oh last
bullet ant ah I missed coming you guys
okay yeah we're good
okay there's a chill music room to
refill get to a century there must be
one lurking around somewhere the memo
pack you know the music's definitely
still freaky for a reason I am out of
ammo
could I get in here it thank you ever
buy me it sees behind a wall Bob let me
repay you with Pingdom uh he was
glitched okay there's two more crates
over here we're clear now what'd you do
to me mark oh you where we have personal
ID okay so it's nothing bad will happen
if I grab the ID card right no it should
be fine yeah there's a lot of those
health health roll-call
23:32 okay and Bob you need this more
this is the last one I have to get
myself oh wait you didn't do it to me
did you do it to yourself
oh my god oh man I'm sorry I was close
to you I thought it would work okay
there's a bunch of stuff we didn't
explore back in the rest this room there
might be more you just be careful
there's not more an amazing what are the
odds of something like that occurring
this is only like the second level isn't
it yes there's a level to another
security scan sequence why is he through
the wall Oh what the hell is that a
tentacle dude if he's moving around then
yes that would be a tentacle dude okay
so he's in the next room
oh yeah there's movement I'm seeing like
10 again
there's one right inside the door lights
off chill chill chill chill
come to me follow me follow me okay okay
okay I'm very far away on me on me on me
straight up ass cheeks rut wait keep
coming wait wait wait there was a
motorist down back yeah let me let me
try to I'm gonna try to mind this she
put the one there see what that does
okay so I realize now I stuff oh god I
should probably put this on walls it
didn't touch any of my minds there
apparently not gonna push so just push
play it slow you saying into battle go
to ones behind the wall and ones to the
right okay
Jack Jack killed the one yeah I know it
still pinged who got try to pick up
these mines can I do that yeah I can do
it please don't explode them would never
God just seeing them standing in the
darkness
oh you're I'm out of shotgun ammo oh my
god I'm not healthy on ammo okay okay oh
no the ass right in the face that's the
worst
oh my god all the things to expect to
see through that door let me check well
yeah would you say there's one right
there is like all right there's some
there's some very close by I think I'm
remembering this room is small there's a
door over here yeah we're good there's a
door right here this room is clear
double lockers I don't know if that's
the tentacle walking around right there
it is if it's moving it's a tentacle my
century is empty my century has a bit we
can use this as a as a choke point if we
want to open it suit happens and then
use this door as the choke and I can
sentry it down okay so should we stand
behind this thing or let's not plan to
fight let's let's open the door and see
what happens any lights off and there no
movement okay there's a Thursday behind
this actually there is two right inside
this door everyone stay back and I'll
wait until that [ __ ] gone if I
remember this this is a really awkwardly
small room that we're about to go into
so oh its tentacle inge oh [ __ ] me okay
so these two are there in an awkward
position you need to be like next to me
I'm coming back do we want to wait for
him to loop just get out of the doorway
Jesus Christ the [ __ ] was that oh my god
oh my god
okay I'm gonna mine what just step back
stay back stay back
oh no no no one's gonna kill us all
this kind of lies Oh watch out for the
range they have a range
yeah just fall back around the corner oh
okay did my mind blow yeah okay boy okay
okay dead dead from behind behind oh my
god where's they come from coming coming
they have licky tongues watch out [ __ ] I
didn't get indication so I didn't show
you more behind more behind or get
through the door get through the door so
many [ __ ] off turret Jesus oh I'm out of
ammo oh boy
hammers out boys okay I think we might
be clear okay you guys are great
holy Jimmy Neutron Jesus Christ how many
things are gonna keep coming from behind
us yeah what door did they bust open to
try to get to us I don't know
hey 20% alright that's like a free med
kit wait wait a quarter of the way they
search what are the clickers I'm seeing
nothing on my scanner okay
I swear to god I was just hearing
clickers yeah you were it's going great
hey I got a tool refill pack good good
personal ID what am i hearing that okay
I'm hearing that groaning but I'm not
seeing anything on the scanner can you
ping the keycard from that terminal
Carter we're looking red 90 zone 43 just
work he red 90 is that's back the other
way that was the alarm door wasn't it we
didn't die no but we have gonna do the
alarm when we're low on health and ammo
well unless they actually came through
that now all right maybe Bob Stitt is
century for me I've got zero revolver
and 14% pistol I'm I'm out of everything
so back I'm not a pistol 30% revived
revolver yeah the security door is still
entire Wade mines aren't the best well
we only use it on the big dude right
yeah I'm gonna mine up the areas that
won't came from and like the distant
areas yeah maybe the door we originally
came through yeah I'm gonna mine that
one are we are we collectively deciding
that we have to do the stupid security
door now yeah wait guys you know what I
don't this there's the cheese you can do
with the turrets in this game you can
place turrets clipped through doors and
they will shoot it stuff in the next
room I totally forgot about that
well ours at the next room it's it
doesn't trigger the enemies it'll just
spin out the herd oh he killed one
problem isn't that room it's the [ __ ]
that we're gonna fight to get enough I
know well better than nothing but that
one's dead so that's some got them can
we kill them all and then do the
security checkpoints or that usual
thinking I don't know waves there's only
a certain amount of it in my imagination
says that as the alarm is blaring it's
just gonna bring more and more that's
what my guess is hmm you know what let's
just [ __ ] do it we don't really have
a game plan I just don't think there's a
good thing to do yeah we don't have the
resources for this I'm at 20% health so
I'm dead in like one hit me to 26%
health o28 baby together we almost have
a full health bar
come here nerds let's do this oh well
here we go we're good I'm just doing
that alright I'm coming from the right
set boned wait did they just change
where they're coming from probably me oh
hey up here
nevermind there it goes mines got mine I
got boned on where mine win or go oh my
god please don't kill me don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me don't kill
me oh okay to the right I'm putting it
on the bridge Jack Jack back back
sorry stay out of any ranged fire oh my
god there's so many Oh God
okay I'm out of turret I'm out of turret
Oh someone just hit the OL gun down to
hammer try and get the ones that are
like wheeling up for attacks okay yeah
is that oh we got oh range on the stairs
on the right stairs range shut up here
it oh god [ __ ] you god I couldn't move
got it I'm at 10 now god well no I have
great news there are like seven more
through the store
that's flag get your turn and choose the
door let's do you heal free fear below
20 your turrets aim your turrets at 120
to 130 fine then there's another one as
close to the door as you can there's
another one at 45 I don't know if my
minds did much I couldn't tell they did
well they definitely helped that was way
more manageable okay good yeah 120 to
130 I like right here 121 yes that
doesn't sound good okay oh no well it's
not killing anything and all right all
right good work guys
I've got zero bullets melee baby I'm
opening the door lights off nerds wait
wait what we did light lights off way to
turn your light off okay two to the
right
oh he already spotted us no [ __ ]
probably the probably the turret did
that we're good oh no I hear they got
more more oh yeah well we are so [ __ ]
no we're not there's at least one one
shooter
yeah I'm focused arrange this down
French it's not all there's another
range
wow what the [ __ ] I fell god damn it I'm
gonna come with you I think that's the
last one possum got him we are Rachel
retail breezing did you take fall damage
from going off or did but don't worry
buy healed it right back up
done we have five of six or twelve
almost done wow this is way bigger than
I thought it was stay behind Jack chill
there's a guy like right below me here
but there's stairs like down down the
stairs in there yeah there's a terminal
right here but oh yeah wait there's that
door down there through the door oh yeah
forty-three I think okay we're gonna
have 43 49 okay oh yeah 43 okay
43 be there's a lot of them on the left
tool refill baby oh god I can't [ __ ]
type Bob I'm gonna give you this while
you're doing that thank you
pinging all right King and King King
pinging pinging can't kinking look just
watch out it's coming well I couldn't
hear cuz you're talking back towards you
guys I'm kinking there's a med pack in
here as well it's in the next room yeah
yeah it's right where I think it's down
here
yeah yeah huh well how do you spell med
pack med kit MIDI kit M e di ki t Oh for
god sakes why am I in charge of typing I
hate all of you just take your time take
it slow you got it take your time type
the letters it's not found
okay ping the key is this 43 it's your
heart that's there the other door is
through here yeah okay so we definitely
know where it is all right I'm gonna
open lights off yep I'm not with you but
I'm sure it's fine oh really in here
okay fine
oh my god I don't like when you say that
there's eight of them through here nine
ten eleven I think well we've got two
centuries with no ammo so I mean wait
doesn't go this long I I will use my
shotgun on the door if L if all goes to
hell just get the [ __ ] out of the way
and let's century these bad boys all
stand back are you ready two centuries
I've got no ammo anymore that's like
it's like right in the way well I'm
looking to melee some stuff yeah let's
do this
there's none right at the door oh wow I
hear all those clickers should we just
trigger them
why would we do that let's see if we can
get some for free probably there's two
where that guy you can see up the stairs
there's two right there all right and
there's a lower on the right on the
right that looks like it would be
through a door so maybe that's not in
here mark I'll follow you guys
careful there's one right there there's
two crawling up here okay yeah so a
bunch of them to poach them or through
that door yeah you're right good I'll
get the one on the far right up against
to the 34 in this room okay okay okay oh
come on we'll move out move out you can
be pretty [ __ ] liberal with your
movements it's all wrong kind of liberal
get ready to smash hammers by the way if
tits go up yep run back out the door we
came in if [ __ ] goes crazy okay I'm
ready okay I am ready okay charge now
and three two one so there's one right
to the left of Merrick right down there
okay now I don't see it right now but I
hear it oh I see it yeah oh there's
another one from our distance like 225
but he's Dee's way away he might be in a
different room okay I'm gonna go for
this one
it's alone right you said it was alone
where's it yeah it should be right it's
like right on me between you and me
right now so yeah getting it there you
go nice nice I think I still hear some
West there's one way west yeah yeah and
there's there's two here but I can't see
the second one there's one I see I see
it I see one by me okay wait wait what
yes yeah I see what you're right there's
one dead in front of me as well that I'm
gonna go for instead okay but the one T
there's another one to your right
Wade you see this guy by himself how far
am i from you men we're very close
we're gonna get these together I mean
one I think you can get those two yeah
let's get these two okay charge now
three two one
had to go had to go because it started
to wake up that's okay okay there's me
one right next to me one further against
the wall he's underneath the forty three
a sign and then you I'm gonna go take
forty three see same okay you're good
start charging now three two one
nice okay this room clear clear yep good
[ __ ] gamers all right KITT I need to use
one American oh no no let me stay at 20
cuz if I go down I don't think being 40%
help then get Bob yeah I got an ammo
pack
well I'm zero zero who else does zero
zero at least have the turret dammit
it's a key card Oh what the [ __ ]
Oh God that scared the crap out of me
it's water dripping that it but it
sounded like clicking oh we can oh [ __ ]
this door let's go back to our main door
again there's the IDS behind that one
there's an alarm we can probably go back
to the main room and then there's no
alarm on that key card door yeah I'm
willing to bet there's one more
personnel ID behind that security I see
what what zone was that actually 44 I
believe okay so then I want to list its
own 44 and find out what we're missing
okay in zone 44 there are there's one ID
of course excuse for a secret ammo pack
there's a medi-pack and there's one ID
and there are like seven lockers I hate
to say this but this is the alarm door
with the ammo in the med pack isn't that
gonna be less of a hassle than the
keycard door well to get through the
security door you need to defend a wave
and we don't have ammo to get to the am
but rookie card
what it last time if the key carrot
doesn't have an alarm on it does it no
oh wait yeah it's the [ __ ] baton even
B key cards the big one with all of the
like stand in this stand in that go over
yeah this is gonna suck matter
alright let's let's look a smaller dick
for a small suck I'm not saying that my
dick smokes it's not it's very very not
small but I know how to handle small big
one alright say my door you guys want a
turret how's the weather okay we good
yeah we good nope
let's do it ah middle left middle left
middle left that's probably this one I
guess okay going first
I don't have any scans yet let's get
more more more more coming in thank god
they're up here okay alright it's done
it's done we just need to survive now I
just need to go over there are they big
no there's more than two there's more
than two oh you are right there are more
than two oh Jesus turret help us for the
love of God help us turn out what the
[ __ ] they're up here yeah there are
[ __ ]
oh I'm down oh [ __ ] I'm down oh [ __ ] I'm
at 3% obvious play cautious it's just
this your health your health comes back
you can get one of us subway tonight
we'll start at 20 if you have a Chan if
you have time I'm up anyone I'm getting
you I'm getting you up I'm getting you
okay that one's down either music I
think we're good oh my god this better
good god where's the thing yeah I think
they came from that other door here
mine's out again I'm sure I'm just
mallet man oh God we're not gonna be
able to hammer these why not are they
big there's one two three four six
can I can I turret cheese them uh yeah
get him turret okay there's one there's
two he's getting the fire ones for some
root three nice okay that's three that's
good okay so there's three left right
inside the door so we should be able to
get Chinese [ __ ] what see them to the
right why didn't your turn get them to
at 58 to 60 up on a Ledge so if that's
just one by itself you can probably get
that one yeah so this over towards the
north they're far away so free here at
105 to 150 yeah okay I'm ready I can't
see I can't even see this dude you see
he's right there chill chill chill chill
mark sorry yeah I'm ready okay charge
now three two one nice mark do more
there's two more on the ledge up here
I'm going to scissor for t-44a I'm gonna
use the computer terminal we saw I've
seen enemy under the sign and one up by
the ledge by me yep and there's another
one over here
there's nothing listen Sifu there's
there's five left in this room by the
way no items listed in this room I got
the ID that was here there's I usually
leave I think we should clear them out
so they don't follow us later
yeah there's no there's health and ammo
and everything right yeah nodded
room that I could see there's a door
connected here that might have some
behind I've got a locker and there's
there's a locker over here too because
there's three up here by me I know
there's three down here as well so yeah
I'm seeing eight dudes on my other mind
they're probably four down here I'm
gonna try to sneak up the side of this
ledge to go around and wait how many are
with you should I come up there's three
up here and they're all side by side
there's two over toward mark and one
kind of by me okay I'm up I'm up here
okay so you can get those all together
and not rebuilt gels chill good question
I'm gonna line up on the middle one okay
you got it you got it
I'm ready but this is probably gonna get
the ones behind me just FYI oh it's got
a face under all this Oh God all right
we ready yep yep start charging now mmm
and three two one get them okay so you
boys two of you goats at those two and
I'll get the one in the hole I'll have
the report out there's only three
there's only three I'm in no position
apparently okay I'm in position I am in
position I'm in position
okay charge now three two one yeah all
the others are through the doors I'll
take the seafoam grenades and said oh
I'll grab the fog repeller because I got
nothing else to pick up so yeah I can
see five there's one kind of close to
the door not immediate okay check what's
here in case it's [ __ ] so how you
doing
um good man good my pinkie Kurtz is
there a way to toggle crouch yeah I
[ __ ] have toggle crouch on oh my god
how where is that I assume it's in game
play or something
oh god enable that Jesus God we're so
we're right on the edge of being Oh
getting kinda free but also we're so
[ __ ] dead
we're fine this whole [ __ ] thing
again if we don't yes yes yeah yes but
we're fine okay I'm gonna open I'm gonna
hide okay looks okay there is one
right in front of me I don't know he's
run up the stairs it looks like he's a
iswe don't know the other door be
helpful other doors up here up the
stairs I think it's clear to go through
that door do you think I should go down
to get that one down there at the same
time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay we're
fine to get both of those and Kay look
at you scooting I'm okay
he appeared in the darkness but I'm in
position okay me too oh wait charge it
there's one more down farther below I
will come around yes and join you guys
down okay I'll just I was hanging out
with this guy Bobby what am I going for
you're gonna take no you're gonna turn
off mine I'm gonna go down below where
this guy is so you're gonna take this
guy Susie oh it's okay everyone relax
I literally have my hands off everything
because paranoid I ruin that's my fault
I've done everything wrong ow ow [ __ ]
watch out for the range watch out for
the range one yeah if you can get if we
can get rid of it oh I'm down I screwed
that hard I'm down calm down I'm down I
screwed it so hard I'm I apologize okay
okay I got some lady foreign aids [ __ ]
yeah it was very close anyways yeah no
that was that was just awkward
I must have bumped him as I want to
turned I think who wants to go low six I
I'm so glad I found sea foam grenades
that time yeah whoo what are we all at
20 now doesn't even mo baby oh yeah
full refill
I have some weights that completely zero
I think I'm coming to you weighty god
zone 45 door wait are you muted yeah he
made it
have I been how long about a mute I must
have accidentally pressed it like an
hour ago you have been quiet for quite a
while do you refuse so I'm gonna heal
each of you guys don't wonder you didn't
answer me I was like mark do you see
that guy on the thing behind you no
weights mark mark wait what's up wait
maro wow oh my dude I got it no ammo but
I do have health I don't have him I've
got I've got sentry him I've got someone
found a my so I've got no pistol or
revolver I didn't get that [ __ ] there's
no clear distinction other than the name
and it looks like kinda wish we'd healed
up Bob now instead of me but that's okay
I'm fine all right what do you guys play
all about this door down here that's the
only one we have what is this don't 45 I
can list it door door locker locker two
IDs three IDs and a sock this is I'm a
security door so we're going to stick
together to do the security thing oh boy
we got this guys we got this we got this
this is where it turns around we get
more health kits we don't take a hit
this entire one it'll be nice good yeah
guys ever since I did the ammo I'm fully
stocked shall we that's a lot that
sounds bad
I'm gonna seafoam this okay we're going
up okay wait what where'd they go oh I'm
going back down okay I'm on one I'm
pinging all right oh god everyone went
down got it okay that's that's that then
okay Alamo Alamo I'm gonna I'm gonna
turn this and let's hide in our
hidey-hole they're coming down this way
the turf waves turn right behind you
wait oh [ __ ] we still have security
things to do oh we do Oh what oh god I
thought it was done oh we've to
[ __ ] oh god I'm taking a lot of hits
from where ah goddamnit I go down like a
[ __ ] I'm dead
mmm oh there's a big boy down at me [ __ ]
Bob it's all on you if you come back
it's all on us oh god okay hell yeah we
were sued by me that might be posted
yeah I'm going I'm getting wait I'm
getting away I'm getting weighed I'm
getting the security thing oh my god
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go around I'm
gonna go around them tied them kite um
yeah kite um
oh [ __ ] oh there's more there's more
comin I'm gonna try to get this security
there's some right on me oh [ __ ] my dad
one's on me Oh God okay okay
Oh
oh my god you know
damn it man gee ha jeez that that
carried noise the funny thing is we got
so much better at the game like we were
playing that last hour 20% and knowing
yeah god imagine having full ammo
[Music]